hello and welcome one and all to wonder
vision no not that one although we can't
understand the confusion this is no
superhero sitcom though this is the
latest innovation from our dear friend
dr wondertainment tell me have you ever
wondered who would win in a fight
between let's say superman and goku is
that pairing a little two by the numbers
okay how about something more like this
godzilla vs
scp-5514 aka the dragon slayer a giant
mech suit designed by the scp foundation
for the sole purpose of taking on giant
city destroying creatures like the old
king of the monsters himself now that's
more like it and scenarios just like
that are exactly what we're here for
friends we've all spent so much time
pondering the what-ifs but as much as it
would be a fun use of our time we can't
all spend our days daydreaming luckily
though dr wondertainment has just the
thing we need how does he do it
introducing his latest and perhaps his
most ingenious creation yet wondervision
through the miracle of the good doctor's
patented and highly secret technology
you can now experience the outcomes of
any fictitious situation you can
possibly think up and all from the
comfort of your own home why waste hours
daydreaming let wondervision do all the
imaginings so you don't have to so are
you ready to take it for a spin
oh of course there are so many
possibilities so many scenarios to think
up it can leave you feeling a little bit
spoiled for choice can't it tell you
what start with a fight scenario those
are always good an old-fashioned
one-on-one grudge match after all who
hasn't wanted to see two things that
would never normally face off with each
other go toe to toe here you input the
first fighter scp-682 a popular choice
the hard to destroy reptile infamously
one of the most fearsome and tenacious
anomalies ever encountered by the scp
foundation whoever you're going to be
pitting against it definitely has their
work cut out for them now you could pick
another scp to fight your first
candidate but why not try something
different really push the boat out after
all with wondervision anything is
possible so come on introducing your
next contender
deadpool ah a comic book fan are we well
once again you've hit on an interesting
choice also known as wade wilson this
canadian mutant from marvel comics is
not only a master of martial arts and
almost every form of combat but much
like your friend as scp-682
he's got a knack for healing even the
worst injuries imaginable this one is
going to be close it also might take a
while oh hey there what's this someone's
youtube video better watch my swears so
let's get started with your match-up
combatants take your places it's time
for round one combatants wait a minute
am i on battle world right now no wait
it's mojo world right okay maybe some
other world obsessed with one-on-one
gladiatoria arena fights is this the ufc
also another question what the hell is
that big angry looking lizard here we go
wonder vision is now generating every
possible outcome let's take a look at
this scenario now we all know that
scp-682 has always been a formidable foe
and one of its attributes that makes it
so fearsome is its size the hard to
destroy reptile is an unambiguous
monster a large quadrupedal creature
spouting two pairs of legs a tail and a
vaguely crocodilian head its mouth
filled with razor sharp teeth but as the
old adage goes the bigger they are the
harder they fall and nobody knows better
about using an opponent's size to his
advantage than the merc with the mouth
you can say that again mr narrator guy
hey do i really have to fight this
killer croc over here oh sorry wrong
universe on top of that good old
deadpool is one of the most highly
skilled swordsmen in the entire marvel
universe rivaled only by the likes of
wolverine taskmaster and blade it's a
pretty well-known fact that those dual
katanas of his aren't just for show call
it overcompensating i dare you
his training and tactics already put our
underdog wade w wilson at a little bit
of an advantage but let's not forget
scp-682 is no slouch either the reptile
is known to be pretty fast when it needs
to be fueled by its own sheer hatred for
all other forms of life that's its
motivation the sole driving force behind
the creature it thinks of anything else
as an abomination whether it be a person
or a plant even other anomalies every
living thing other than itself are
unforgivable
unnatural and disgusting to scp-682
and it will stop at nothing to kill
anything it sees of course that is a
little tricky when the only person
nearby is a mutant with a similar
penchant for bodily regeneration as well
as a notoriously big mouth as fast as
the hard to destroy reptile can be it is
hindered its own slightly larger size
can make the creature cumbersome it
isn't by much but it's just enough for
our old pal deadpool to get to work
doing what he does best unsheathing his
pair of pristine swords wade flies into
battle as gung-ho as ever he lands the
first blow lodging one of his blades in
scp-682's reptilian musculature the
reptile lets out a furious war one that
would strike fear into anybody else but
deadpool well he's not exactly the
fearful type more the too insane to back
down type now the hard to destroy
reptile's hide is pretty thick usually
providing it with enough protective
layers to defend the creature against
more conventional forms of attack guns
bombs knives or in this case swords but
the adaptability and resistance of
scp-682
is only matched by deadpool's
resourcefulness also his reckless and
wildly unpredictable nature but speaking
of resourceful his swords sometimes
known as bay and arthur aren't forged
from any ordinary metal wiley old wade
wilson has been known to wield katanas
made out of carbonadium a metal that can
not only deflect powerful incoming
attacks but the element itself is also
able to disrupt the healing factor of
certain mutants like wolverine the
sharpened carbonadium slices through the
scaly leather hide of scp-682
much to the reptile's disgust and
annoyance it moves to retaliate swiping
at the mutant mercenary with its claws
each as sharp as the blades of
deadpool's weapons his natural reflexes
kick in slightly enhanced by the process
that triggered his mutation and his
rigorous special ops training deadpool
blocks the oncoming attack by crossing
both swords above his head but the force
behind
scp-682's blows staggers him you see he
might be slightly faster than the
life-hating lizard thanks to his smaller
size but deadpool simply doesn't possess
the same muscle mass and bodily strength
as a gigantic monster but he can still
hold his own hey watch the cheeky double
entendre there mr narrator god this
gekko's jacked deploying a spin maneuver
guiding the heavy limb of
over his head deadpool uses his katanas
like a pair of giant carbonadium
scissors a move that would make abel
proud he cleaves off one of the
monster's arms slicing through the thick
hide into muscle and bone beneath
causing the creature to lose its footing
tumbling forward over itself using the
beast's fall to his advantage deadpool
leaps onto
scp-662's back raising his two swords he
plunges the blades into the crocodilian
head of the monster each one stabbing
directly through its skull sprays of
blood brains and viscera spew from the
wound not that you can tell from the
state of deadpool's suit that's why he
wears red after all you joke but do you
have any idea how hard this is going to
be to wash out i'm talking tide pen
seltzer water and lemon i swear if any
of these stains set in unfortunately
deadpool does have a penchant for
getting distracted partly fighting back
out of aggression and possibly partly
due to finding the motor mouth mutant to
be a bit of a nuisance
scp-682 quickly rolls over onto its back
startled by the sudden movement deadpool
loses his balance and falls to the
ground quickly followed by the weight of
a giant hard to destroy reptile like we
said the bigger they are the harder they
fall pinned under the beast wade reaches
for b trying to use the sword as a
makeshift crutch to pull himself free
hey i'm down but not out let me in coach
i'll bite his scaly ankles off back on
his two feet and finding himself facing
an enemy back on four deadpool opts for
a more scorched earth approach it's time
for scenario two few people know this
about our dear friend mr wilson but he
actually has more than a few tricks up
his blood stained sleeves or rather in
his magic satchel yes you heard that
right the equipment bag deadpool is
normally seen wearing has its own extra
normal properties to it the satchel
itself contains a near infinite pocket
dimension along with the ability to
create anything that the user needs
extra ammo replacement swords and an
endless supply of stuffed unicorns hey
how'd you know about those you name it
and deadpool can produce it from his bag
in a matter of seconds again we really
need to get this guy and able to hang
out sometime don't we say what you will
about the speed and ferocity of one of
the foundation's most notorious
anomalies but no reptile has an
abundance of extra hardware in its
pocket you know that's not a bad idea i
mean i'm not just doing this because you
said i would or who knows maybe i am hey
croc i hope you like pineapple with that
deadpool unleashed a volley of grenades
all pulled from the extra dimensional
satchel and launched straight at
scp-682 the ensuing explosions are
deafening engulfing the hard to destroy
reptile and the area around it in flames
and debris
luckily the writers let me have my bag
with me i honestly don't think i'd stand
a fighting chance without him
unfortunately as we mentioned earlier
scp-682 is pretty thick-skinned able to
resist a lot of the explosive punishment
deadpool is stealing out conventional
weapons even combustible materials and
ordinance do little to cause the
creature any lasting harm and mainly
serve to anger the reptile even further
oh come on man what about if i use this
pulling a bazooka from his magical
satchel deadpool launches the most
destructive expensive and excessive
explosive he can think of a
diamond-tipped high-velocity
heat-seeking warhead the missile lets
loose piercing the outer layer of
scp-682 scales and lodging itself deep
in its side as the creature turns to
deflect the full force of the oncoming
ordnance the reptile roars in pain and
aggression to feel the super dense tip
of the projectile burrowing into it
through its thick defensive exterior and
into its flesh you might want to cover
your ears for what follows hey stop
addressing the audience that's my bit
wait what was that about covering our
ears with an almighty boom the warhead
detonates spewing flame and chunks of
charred scp-682 in every conceivable
direction smoke fills the space around
them as the monstrous creature hisses in
contempt thrashing in pain suddenly a
large-scale covered tail whips out of
the smoke still suffering from a nasty
bout of military-grade tinnitus from the
blast deadpool looks up only too late as
a powerful appendage swipes at him
sending the merc with the mouth reeling
scp-682
is far from dead as the fumes from the
detonation clear its smoldering wound is
already starting to heal but that gives
deadpool an idea reaching into his magic
satchel wade fishes out another grenade
the moment his gloved hand grabs it
another roar fills the area the hard to
destroy reptile begins barreling towards
the regenerating mutant in red bearing
its wide maw of sharp teeth well this is
a terrible idea pulling out a fresh
grenade deadpool charges directly
towards the oncoming reptile wrenching
the pin from the handheld explosive and
flicking free the safety handle he leaps
up into the air aiming to achieve a
balletic flip over the head of the angry
monster with its tenacious and loudmouth
prey in mid-air above it
scp-682 lifts its jaws upwards just as
deadpool turns around to drop the primed
grenade into the hard to destroy
reptile's mouth this goes about as well
as you'd expect deadpool is caught right
between the large crocodilian jaws of
scp-680
the monstrous anomaly plucks the
acrobatic assassin out of the air with
ease but in his hand he's still got the
grenade and its timer is rapidly ticking
down another in a series of huge
deafening explosions rips through the
head of scp-682
before the reptile has a chance to
swallow deadpool and his grenade thanks
in equal parts to the sharp teeth
tearing him apart as well as the blast
of his own grenade there's not much
remaining of deadpool that's still alive
nope i'm fine really just give me a few
hours to grow back my you know entire
body actually uh could someone come and
pick my head up no that's okay i'll just
roll i guess well technically deadpool
is still alive thanks to his mutation
much like his opponent
scp-682 here his regenerative healing is
so effective he can continue to function
even when the rest of his body skeleton
nervous system internal organs is
completely obliterated then again just
blowing off the hard to destroy
reptile's head is only enough to
temporarily slow it down this is the
same creature that survived being cut in
half by a laser and having its neck
snapped repeatedly over 10 hours by
scp-173 so while these two are gradually
reconstituting themselves again why
don't we just chalk this one up to a tie
a tie come on man hey i'm still wait for
it wait for it ahead of the competition
anyone
rough crowd let's just jump ahead a few
hours and give these two a chance to
heal up now by this point our old pal
deadpool has used most of his go-to
options for a fight and they're not
exactly proving to be all too effective
against
scp-682 hey i'm doing my best here the
hard to destroy reptile on the other
hand is still fresh for a fight as
extensively healing itself rarely tires
the creature out combine that with the
rage that just won't be quelled and a
opponent who isn't just another form of
life but another living being who also
can't be killed without regenerating and
all that adds up to one very angry
lizard and not a lot of other options
for deadpool other options huh okay i
can think of a few with that deadpool
vanishes just like that in the blink of
an eye he's gone it's not unprecedented
for him after all he does possess a
particular piece of technology that
allows him to do this deadpool has been
known to sometimes wear a teleportation
bracelet a device created by his friend
and go-to for gadgets weasel as to
exactly where he's gone to that's
anyone's guess it's a bold strategy just
trying to outrun scp-682 instead of
facing it but admittedly a little
expected from ta-da
okay i'm back and i brought new toys in
an astounding and completely baffling
move deadpool teleports right back to
where he was just standing brandishing a
golden glove with six shining gemstones
encrusted in it the infinity gauntlet
plot armor much
scp-682 seems to know what this artifact
is or is at least wary of it and keeps
its distance bet you weren't expecting
this
later gator acting with a reckless
abandon typical of nobody other than him
wade snaps his fingers historically only
beings of immense power are able to
wield the infinity gauntlet and survive
the cosmically powerful metal glove is
designed to combine the effects of the
six infinity gems each one governing a
different aspects of existence namely
time space reality power the mind and
the soul as deadpool's fingers click
scp-682 is wiped from existence turning
into nothing more than a pile of dust
floating through the air unfortunately
for wade wielding it the gauntlet's
cosmic energy is so uncontainable that
it is channeled back at him almost
obliterating him entirely
worth it though let's see brolin top
that to make matters worse
scp-682 isn't down for long while
deadpool's own healing factor is
struggling to restore him the hard to
destroy reptile is rapidly
reconstituting itself knitting its
physical form back into existence on a
cellular level fueled by sheer hatred
and willpower rummaging through the
small collection of objects he brought
back with him when he returned deadpool
slips on a metal helmet onto his head
this is no ordinary helmet though it's
cerebro a powerful device used by
professor charles xavier a powerful
psychic that uses the helmet to amplify
his powers and find fellow mutants
although what wade had planned for it is
anyone's guess oh well i'm glad you
asked i'm technically brain dead so i
figured i could use this doohickey to
connect my mind to the big nasty lizard
over there then i can project my own
brain death into him and finally put an
end to this wild ride while it is indeed
an interesting plan there are
unfortunately some pitfalls of
deadpool's latest tactic one being that
only incredibly powerful psychics like
professor x gene grey or emma frost can
even attempt to connect their mind to
cerebral the other snare in the plan is
that's not how cerebral works at all
it's for tracking mutants not projecting
someone's consciousness into the mind of
another oh come on i've been fighting
this lizard with you semi-sarcastically
chastising me all afternoon cut me a
break here all i have left is this
little whatchamacallit that i stole from
that stretchy poindexter with scp-682
once again bearing down on him deadpool
aimlessly fires the weapon unbeknownst
to him the device he's currently holding
is the ultimate nullifier the most
devastating weapon in the entire
universe the blast from the nullifier
envelopes as cp 682 completely and
utterly eliminating it violating the
very law of conservation of mass hey
what do you know it worked say can i go
now wow this thing is getting hot oh
look a penny one downside of using the
ultimate nullifier is that it can often
backfire completely destroying the
person wielding it too especially if
their mind isn't strong enough or if
they lose focus and well sadly deadpool
has a knack for getting distracted while
the nullifier continues to obliterate
both its target
scp-682 and its wielder deadpool its
power destroys the entire universe from
beginning to end this power continues
until it is the only thing left in
existence only to then collapse back in
on itself the ultimate nullifier ends up
paradoxically nullifying its own effect
ultimately then recreating the entire
universe in the blink of an eye
including deadpool and scp-682
so we guess that's another tie oh come
on
now go check out scp-096 versus scp-173
to see the outcome of another chaotic
clash between the shy guy and the
sculpture or for more tips on how to
take down a certain regenerating reptile
go and watch was scp-682 really that
hard to kill after all